I'm really looking forward to sharing
some great content with you all actually
the goal of today's webinar is give you
some really practical information around
partnering we're going to move fast
because I want to give you as much as I
can in the limits of time we have and
I've been driving partner marketing for
a while now as well as channel
development and it never gets old
and these are all tools that I myself
actually use so when we look at the
agenda for today we're going to talk
about frameworks for thinking of partner
relationships gonna give you a few tools
for structuring success and then give
you a guide that I actually use to put
it all in action with my teams and now
my team at Twilio actually so let's
start off with some frameworks for
thinking about partnering relationships
but we should probably take one little
step back which is to talk about why do
you partner now that seems pretty
obvious to most of us oh yeah you gotta
have partners right well there's some
very specific reasons and benefits
around having partners so let's go
through a few of those first of all
companies will partner to enable focus
there are things that you really want to
put your talent and your resources on
and there are other things that are just
stuff you have to get done so if you can
find a partner can get that stuff done
so you can focus on what you do really
well it can be a huge benefit to the
company people partner to to reduce
costs that can be across any line of
things for manufacturing to services to
just delivering a great product so
reducing costs another great reason to
partner people partner for market access
oftentimes the company will be able to
get in my market we mean both geographic
markets and also vertical markets
they'll be able to get into one market
very easily but not know how to
penetrate another region or vertical or
area of the world and they'll use
partners to be able to get that access
we partner for customer access sometimes
you'll have a great offering something
that you really want to move to market
but you can't get to those customers you
really want to get to and partner can
help you with that we partner to
complete the solution we may not have
all the pieces ourselves and I've had
this happen to me and a number of
companies over time and so you'll
partner to find other people can help
you complete the solution to talk about
that
a little bit more in depth we partner
for innovation and differentiation a lot
of companies that will have this great
product that they have offers out there
they'll have a great service out there
but they don't have that innovation
capability inside and they'll find
partners who can actually do it
oftentimes and I've actually sent a
couple of customers I do this they may
actually don't acquire that company in
the end for that ability to be able to
continue that innovation and
differentiation we partner to expand
sources of revenue there may be
offerings that someone else has that
could really complement the portfolio of
what you're already offering and by
bringing those into your portfolio and
leveraging your sales team you can
actually create new sources of revenue
we partner to expand resource access you
see this a lot in industrial companies
where they need to have natural resource
access and I'm sure there are other
reasons as well why people partner but
important to think about all the
benefits that partnering could actually
bring to you so let's jump to our first
framework and that's really looking at
how you might segment the different
types of partners you're working with to
really keep this simple I boil it down
to three buckets first bucket is
supplier partners second bucket is
distribution partners third bucket is
influence partners and we'll talk a
little bit about each of these so first
of all supplier partners probably pretty
obvious the strategic question you have
to ask yourself is am I going to buy it
or am I going to build it and the role
of that supplier partner then becomes to
complete the solution which we just
spoke to enabling a faster
time-to-market facilitating focus on the
core competencies that a company has
giving a competitive advantage and
reducing costs all things we just spoke
to distribution partners key question
you have to ask yourself here is do I
want to go in directly to the market or
directly to the market and the role of a
distribution partner then is to extend
that sales reach accelerate sales and
reduce costs in a third bucket which is
one that people often forget about to
think about really as partners when
they're thinking about this full
portfolio approach our influencer
partners strategic question there is am
I better to go together with someone
else into the mark
or should I do it alone the role there
is influence partners can provide brand
leverage extend market reach and they
can afford some cost sharing in the
process so let's take a little deeper
into each one of these the first one is
that idea of the supplier partner and
the tool that I have always found
effective in looking at who are all the
partners that I might need to bring my
full product to market is something we
call the whole product the whole product
is that minimum set of products and
complementary services that are needed
to fulfill on that value proposition
that compelling reason to buy when
you're going into the marketplace and I
actually will create this circle map and
lay out the different pieces that I need
when I am looking at the whole product
and bringing into the market now one of
the areas that people often forget about
when they're thinking about suppliers is
the services side most customers whether
it's a consumer or a
business-to-business environment they
have expectations of getting this very
complete solution inclusive of all the
services and services can actually be a
great differentiator around a product so
really think carefully about the whole
product and in addition to just the
product components you might need what
are the services that you're also going
to need and are there partners that
would be more effective in helping you
deliver that coming now to our question
of do I need a distribution partner one
of the things here and again a tool that
I have found useful is thinking about
what is my distribution strategy but
thinking of it in the context of high
touch and low touch so if you have an
offering in the market which is really
easy to market and understand and the
solution that you're delivering the
product you're delivering the offering
you're delivering isn't that complicated
to deploy you can go into a low touch
model and therefore you can look for
partners that offer that low touch
environment it may be someone that has a
website that can be able to they can
distribute your product as well or your
service offering through the website it
may be a retail store where there's not
a lot of involvement from the sales
folks if on the other hand what you're
bringing to market has super high
complexity in terms of making people
understand it or understand some element
like the pricing plan mobile phones are
a great example of this you think of
mobile
is easy to buy but that pricing plan
makes it actually really complex to
understand or the solution complexity is
very high in terms of actually getting
something up and running then you're
going to want to have a more high touch
model and look for partners that can
offer that someone that has a true
Salesforce I can go in and sit down with
a customer so when you're thinking about
your distribution partners think about
your distribution strategy think about
it in the context of low touch and high
touch that'll help you get a good
feeling for what type of partners are
actually going to be feasible for you to
work with and then the third bucket that
we had on our list are the influencer
partners and as I said these are the
ones that often get forgotten because
they don't think of them really as
partners but when you're looking at
total portfolio management in a partner
arrangement you want to make sure that
these folks get factored in so let's
talk about different type of influence
partners there are marketing partners
these are folks that you go to market
with and you get great brand association
with them you can do some demand
creation a lot of this we're in the
holiday time you see a lot of this
during holiday times we're two totally
different companies maybe it's wine and
chocolate come together to be able to
bring something to market and it really
is about a marketing partnership you'll
see side-by-side selling partners these
are folks that hey they're going into an
account you have something that their
account might like there's some value
that you can bring together and they
bring you in and work with you but again
there's no passing of money
there's no supplier type relationship
distribution type of relationship it's
just going in and selling side-by-side
Association partners it can be really
super interesting drawing on my path
actually before tech started off in the
aerospace industry we had something
called a helicopter Association
International everyone in the helicopter
industry belonged to it that group
affiliation of being able to get
together in a common place and time read
the same publications really helped
develop the offering that we had in the
market there in ecosystem partners their
value is really that idea of network
effect I think a great example here is
when you think about mobile phones and
that huge system of folks that they have
around from the people that make the
cases to the people who make the apps
there's a whole network effect that is
created by an ecosystem of partners
and then and you see this a lot overseas
there is the idea of government partners
partners who really endorse the business
of what you're doing so important to
also think about influencer partners so
kind of first framework we have here is
thinking about the different types of
partners and how you might segment that
portfolio of partners you're going to
have to manage all right we're gonna now
move on to another framework that I like
which is really thinking about what is
that role of the partner and some
partners focus are focused on more than
just the profit you might get from the
relationship so the way this framework
is really set up is to look at what is
the revenue and profit potential from
the partner versus what are the core
competencies they might help you to
deliver so partnerships can be more than
just about money they can be about
making you a better company and so I
will look at the partners that I'm
working with and kind of look at where
do they fit in terms of this framework
so let's start with kind of the easy
ones
so if someone has low revenue potential
for you or a low profit potential and
they're also not going to do much to
help you develop your core competencies
call that a limited partner you should
probably limit how much you do with that
partner as well probably not gonna bring
you a lot of value the other corner
strategic partner again pretty easy to
look at revenue and profit potential is
high they can really help you develop
your core competencies this is a really
important partner as a part of your
portfolio and then looking at the other
two quadrants if a partner is great at
helping you drive revenue but maybe not
as helpful to you in terms of developing
your core competencies we call that an
earning partner and then in a lower
bottom corner their learning partner
these are folks that may not help you
drive a lot of revenue or profit but
actually they're going to help you
develop your core competencies as a
business so another framework in
thinking about partner relationships is
to think about is this about the money
is this about the core competencies that
I might be able to develop through this
relationship what's the right mix helps
you think about the role that this
partner really helps you play now this
has been a very much an inside what I
call an inside-out discussion what does
it mean to me what's the value to me as
a company
it's also really important to think
about partnering relationships from an
outside-in perspective what this means
is what's the value back to them and I
actually ran into this situation where I
had a core component technology was
great technology it was a sexy
technology everyone wanted to talk about
it we relied on partners as distribution
partners in this case they were all out
there creating the buzz which obviously
had some value to us because it helps us
spread word of mouth and get the word
out about what the company was doing but
what we found out in the process when
our revenues weren't going up the way we
thought they should for all the
distribution partners we had we really
dug in to understand the value from an
outside-in perspective and what we found
out was they were really sexy to talk
about but in the end the productivity
from a revenue perspective for those
distribution partners just wasn't that
high they had other things in their
toolbox that they wanted to sell stuff
that was going to retire sales quotas a
lot faster and what we found was that we
were in the position of being an orphan
product super hot and sexy to talk about
but not really that thing at the end of
the day that the partner was out there
selling so another way to think about
partners is from an outside-in
perspective and understand from the
partners perspective am i a mainstream
product that they're gonna be out there
selling they're all talking about that
they're gonna want to build great things
around because they see it as good
revenue for them am i a product that is
somewhat adjacent or contiguous to what
that partner is doing so interesting but
not rocket ship stuff am i an unworthy
product mean there's no relationship at
all that we should be having or in my an
orphan product someone that's kind of
sexy to talk about but not gonna drive a
lot of revenue so important thought here
is always look at relationships from an
inside-out perspective but also take
that outside in perspective as well all
right so a few frameworks to think about
partnering thinking about why am i
partnering first framework we looked at
was looking at what was going on in
terms of our partner portfolio
segmentation we had that opportunity to
talk about what roles do these partners
really play for us and then talked about
that inside out and outside in
perspective
it's just a partnership that's going to
be successful so now I want to share
with you some tools for structuring
success and again these are tools that I
have actually used in practice so one of
the hardest parts about managing a
partner portfolio for success is how do
you distribute the resources and I've
always found that there seem to be
always more mouths to feed than budget
resources to actually give out and
another thing that's really hard in all
this is saying no in fact for me that's
one of the toughest thing about strategy
in general is it's harder to say no than
yes and so making the tough decisions
where you're going to align those
resources becomes really key so gonna
give you three tools for working with
that and thinking about resource
alignment so this first one looks at
that question of value again value to
the partner and value to the company and
then looking at where you actually apply
the resource now what I've actually done
is taken this and I've actually mapped
out where my partner's fit in terms of
the different quadrants just to give me
a general guide of what I should do but
also to make sure I'm in alignment with
my colleagues on how we should be
addressing a giving partner relationship
so again we'll start with the easy ones
if it's there's low value to the partner
and low value to your company then you
probably have a misfit here and
shouldn't be spending any time or
resources around this partner you may be
sitting I add that's actually very
obvious but the reality is it does
happen and if you dig into your own
partner portfolio you're probably gonna
be surprised to find that there are
actually some companies there that a
nice people oh they contacted us at a
trade short of bed we wanted to do some
business with them but there was really
never a good fit for the relationship so
don't put any resources there the other
one that's super easy it's the strategic
partner bucket these are ones where
there's a high value to the partner
there's a high value to your company and
this is where the bulk of your resources
should be going in terms of investment
in the partner relationships and now
going to our other two corners if there
is a high value to the partner but not
as much value to your company this is
probably an opportunistic relationship
you're gonna put some money in
you're gonna put some people time into
it but at the end of the day you're
probably gonna get that partner company
to put in more resources than you would
to the relationship because it's more
important to them flipside lower box
back to earth and status if it's high
value to your company maybe not as high
value to that other company that you're
working with then you will probably the
one that puts more resources into it
then that partner does so good tool for
thinking about resource alignment
thinking about where your partnerships
fall and then making sure that everyone
in your company has the same perspective
because you will end up where other
departments are contributing to the
partner relationship and you want to
make sure that everyone's in balance so
gonna jump to our next tool this one
again same kind of a four box set up but
instead of looking at it from a value
perspective of value to the partner and
value to you as an individual this tool
has you look at it from a perspective of
strategic value of the relationship and
the growth potential of that
relationship now growth could mean any
variety of things it could mean the
amount of revenue that you can drive
together it could mean the type of new
products that you could innovate on
together it could be in terms of the
number of customers that you would be
able to impact because of either the
right product or the distribution but
again thinking about partner values
thinking about alignment of resources I
will actually sit down and plot again
where do my partners fit in terms of
growth potential and strategic value and
in this particular tool what I do is I
sit down with the team and look at
alright how do we manage the
relationship in each of these four boxes
so if someone is high growth potential
and high strategic value what are the
specific things that we're willing to do
for them if someone is high strategic
value but low growth potential there's
probably another set of logical things
that we would do as a company around
that partnering relationship so second
tool for thinking about where do my
partner's fit in terms of my business
and what am I going to do in terms of
managing that account relationship
all right third tool in terms of how we
do the resource alignment this one gets
very tactical what you'll see here at
each of the bubbles are a list of
bullets where we actually give specific
things that we're going to give to the
partnering relationship by the way this
is actually one that we used at one of
my prior companies and what you're
seeing are actually the things we were
willing to give and here what we looked
at was the amount of resource that we
were willing to give and the amount of
time that we were really going to give
to that partnering relationship here
we're looking at partners as
opportunistic partners ones that we're
not sure how far the relationships going
to go but it's interesting enough that
we want to be a part of it
tactical relationships were well we got
to have them let's go out and make them
as successful as we can and then
strategic relationships again that
partnership that's made in heaven
they're the the relationships that are
good for both of the partners and we
have specifically that listed for those
strategic relationships in this case we
were willing to do a joint business plan
joint development we were happy to
prepackaged a repeatable solution we
were happy to do joint client
development as opposed to the
opportunistic scenario where we said
okay for partners that fall in the
opportunistic bubble we'll do some
subcontracting we'll do some marketing
collateral we'll do some joint training
with them so as a tool again your dots
are going to be different thinking about
what kind of resources and what kind of
time am I willing to put into this
partnership and then what are the
specific things that I'm going to give
to those different types of partners so
three different tools three different
ways of managing for success because the
key to managing for success around a
partnership is making sure you're
getting the right resources to the right
partners at the right time okay super
critical I didn't know about this quite
frankly till probably about 10 years ago
but there's a different type of
proposition for partners than there is
for customers and used to always think
the value proposition that'll apply to
everyone and what you really start
learning when you dig into it is that
partners are very different and there is
this construct of the partner business
proposition and this business
proposition answers are
simple question for the partner why
should we bet our resources and
reputation on you this contrasts with
the traditional value proposition that
you've probably encountered in marketing
which is why should I buy your product
the reason this is so important is if
you can't articulate why a partner
should be betting their resources on you
chances are that's not going to be a
strong partnership
it might even fit into that misfit
bucket that we've talked about so let's
compare the two so when we think about
contrasting the propositions a value
proposition is all focused on the
product that you've got it's all focused
on the objective of selling products
using that value proposition and it's
generally built at out by looking at
what are the features we offer and then
what are the benefits that they return
to our customers when you're looking to
write the business proposition for
partnerships it's focused obviously on
the partners and it's about creating a
bias towards you through that business
proposition so the partner looks at it
goes well there's no way we couldn't
partner this is this is something we
have to go do and the attributes of it
rather than being features and benefits
are more aligned to things like profit
incremental sales strategic value the
things that are going to get that
partner jazzed about working with you
now one of the things that I like to do
is before I actually go in and meet a
partner and start discussing how we're
going to work together is really think
through and understanding their business
what is that business proposition I'm
going to put on the table to make them
really see the value and what we can go
do together so challenge you if you're
managing partnerships do you have a
business proposition that sticks for
each of those partners that you have in
that portfolio and that'll also help you
assess where they fit in some of the
quadrants that we've spoken about so
business propositions super important
tool for making that partnership
successful all right this is an oldie
but a goodie you've probably heard about
this before when you've looked at
partnerships but it's that classic give
to get model what is the partner going
to give me what is it that I really want
for them and what can the partners get
from me
returned I've seen this tool used in a
number of ways I've seen people actually
use it as a way to prep for going into
the first meeting and sitting down and
talking about why this relationships
kind of good at the business proposition
but now here are the specifics of what I
want to get from you and what I can give
you in return
and have that discussion I've also seen
people take this tool and actually sit
down with a blank and have that first
discussion where you're sitting side by
side and saying hey let's walk through
what the gives to guests are in this
relationship and interestingly I've seen
in some very large corporations in fact
they actually line up a 6x6 meeting
meaning six of their people six of our
people and sit down through the day to
actually create a working model of what
the gives to get are going to be when
that relationship is actually brought to
fruition so this one has a number of
stakes that might be potential stakes in
the partnership you can come up with
your own that you think are more
relevant this one looks at all right
what technology is out there what
product platform process technologies
can the partner give to me and what
could I give back to them in return what
are the resources money time talent
knowledge that might be involved in the
partnership what relationships might be
important a lot of this goes back to
that original construct of why partner
so effective tool for again managing
successful partnerships so something to
think about and if you have a
partnership for up and running sit down
and see if you can't put this together
all right
so now kind of a short checklist best
practices essentials of partnering a lot
of this may seem very obvious but again
always good to go back and look at is
this what I'm doing in terms of managing
the current partnerships I'm in so
bullet number one be sure you understand
the contractual relationship you have
with a partner may seem funny but how
many of you actually read all the
individual wide items in a partnership
that's someone else's job to do that's a
legal thing right I understand the
contractual relationship be sure your
partner understands the value you bring
to the relationship they may just think
it's all about them you want to make
sure they understand what you're doing
here be sure you understand the value
the partner brings to you
have a business plan that includes your
partner your partners are just this
thing over here and they're not really a
part of how the business is developing
and growing then that's kind of the way
the resources are gonna sit as well
they're gonna be kind of yeah some of
those little resources over there so if
the company really sees partnerships as
important make sure they're a part of
the business fund that you put together
get the top people in line in the
organization with what you're doing with
these partners again you don't want them
to be kind of that quiet group off in
the corner you want partners to be super
successful and that takes a whole
organization rallying around the fact
that they've got partners that are
important to the business personally we
work to make the partnership successful
don't take it for granted if it's
important to the business invest the
time relationship building is so
undervalued today we're so used to email
we're so used to social networks at the
end of the day business is still about
people and quite a good reason to
partner this gets back to that whole
thing about the misfit partner I can't
tell you how many times I've run into
relationships and companies where
they've agreed to partner yeah I'd like
you let's go do something and there's
really not a good reason to partner
something to look at a few more
don't tell your partner what you think
he wants to hear tell them the truth
that's the only way a relationship is
going to yield the results that you
expected to when conflict does arise
seek to understand their point of view
don't only think of it from your point
of view and what has created the the
angst
never talk in a negative manner about
your partner in front of a third party
if you guys are partners you've picked
them they've picked you be very positive
hope something whole relationship thing
respect your partner's way of doing
business they may especially if you're
working on a global basis they may just
fundamentally think differently about
things so understand it don't let one
incident spoil a relationship and those
incidents are going to happen so make
sure that you take a step back take a
deep breath and figure out how to make
things go forward stick with your
partner and good and bad times their
business is going to change and evolve
and part of a partnering relationship is
being there for each other and then
focus on his added value at the end of
the day so just some things some best
practices some ways to think about how
to make those partnerships successful
and
and a last tool partnering lifecycle
what you see over on the left is the
stage of the lifecycle on the right the
general description of it and
partnerships are a lot like personal
relationships they grow and they change
over time understanding where your
partners fit from a life cycle
perspective is important because you're
going to do some things differently
you're going to treat the relationship
potentially differently and
interestingly you will find every
partnership going through the same type
of a life cycle you have the early face
the dating phase partners are sizing
each other up firms are mobilizing
internal support for the Alliance a lot
of energy about how we're going to get
this together how are we going to make
it successful and you also really see a
lot of attention to it and so people are
on their game then you get into that
growth phase that hey we got this thing
going you want to make sure that it's
continuing for it but you have to
demonstrate commitment to it because
it's really easy especially if you're
building up multiple partnerships to go
for the shiny object let's go put all
that energy into the new partnership
make sure you invest in that grow space
and you understand that you're in the
growth phase and then there is a
maturity phase there is that kind of oh
oh we've been together for a while you
know should we still be doing this is
this still the right marriage to be a
part of and it's about really revisiting
that relationship understanding the
value contracts may be up for
renegotiation deciding whether this is
still the right relationship are you
still in it because you've been in it
for a long time go back and look at your
partner in relationships think about
where they actually sit in each phases
of these life cycles and think about are
you treating it all the same or are you
actually treating each phase of the life
cycle slightly differently because you
will find you will have a more
successful relationship if you commit to
this idea of there is a life cycle
behind the relationships we're working
in so those are some tools for
structuring success there are a ton more
out there but I thought those would be
particularly interesting for today so
now we're going to put this all into
action this is actually a tool that I
developed for my own use with my team
and what I found the real value for of
it was really aligning on the view to
relationships and so it's
strategy overview for relationships it
has four parts this is actually a
template that you can go use it as the
relationship overview the opportunity
overview the business overview and then
the success overview you can use this in
different ways you can use it as hey
we've got a lot of partners out there
they won't want to work with us and you
can fill this out and then you can use
it as a tool for everyone to review and
decide which partners are we going to
work with you can use it as a management
tool having people actually fill this
out and then come back and check on it
are we really getting what we wanted out
of this are we really managing the
relationship the way we thought so use
it in the way you want but let's cover
each of the areas first one is the
relationship overview some very simple
questions to ask and again I don't make
this a lot of written copy I use bullets
just to keep it simple otherwise I find
people won't do it
but first question is nature of the
partnership going back to our buckets
this is supplier distributor or
influencer from a partnering perspective
history of the relationship is that new
have there been previous entering
interactions what's the state of the
relationship where are we in the
lifecycle what's the level of the
relationship some partners will be at
the executive level gotta have my CEO
talk to your CEO others will be at more
of a manager level understanding where
that is and understanding if you're
aligned it's really important nothing
worse than coming to a meeting and
there's their CEO and you've got the
purchasing manager importance of the
relationship is it strategic
opportunistic tactical the expected
length of the relationship are we in
this for a short thing or is this for a
long thing so understanding that and
making sure everyone is aligned
opportunity overview so what's the
problem statement why are we partnering
what's being addressed this is a
business problem or a technical problem
what's the size of the problem or the
opportunity what are the metrics that
outline kind of the size of the velocity
that we see this partnerships taking off
on ramifications what happens if the
problem we've just defined this
partnerships in to help us solve is the
distribution problem is that a supply
issue we have what happens if the
problem isn't addressed and are there
any compelling motivators reasons to act
and act quickly business overview so
combined offer to market going to be
what does this relationship actually
yield it's going to yield greater sales
it's going to yield a whole brand new
product it's going to develop new
technologies we've never thought of
before what are the goals and objectives
is it a revenue objective a market reach
objectives going back to kind of those
why do you partner questions we started
off with what's that business
proposition
not the value proposition but why that
partner should invest their resources in
this relationship and then what am i
gives to gets all some of that all the
tools we were just talking about and
then the success overview the enablers
that's gonna make this partnership
actually work negative
risks what are the blockers need to be
aware of those we need to counter those
if we think they're real and then
measurement what does success look like
three months out six months out and
twelve months out so a lot of content
told you we're gonna work through it
fast want to give you as many tools as
possible but you have some frameworks
for thinking about partnering
relationships you've got some tools to
help you structure for success and
you've got my tool for putting all that
stuff into action and making sure that
you have a true portfolio of
partnerships that you can manage and
really make a difference in your
business so that's it that's all I got
so we have a quite a few questions I'm
going to start out with this one so and
again if you have questions when I try
to get to them all we may not I
apologize for that so first question
here is is there anything different in
your approach to managing and measuring
partnerships where the partner isn't it
for him for hire or an outside resource
partner ah interesting question actually
one of the companies that you heard I
was a part of was a company called gent
act which was actually a Business
Process Outsourcing
so I've had an opportunity to spend some
time in that world you know the reality
is it's a partnership and so if you are
hiring a partner to help you you can
have the exact same expectations in
terms of to give to gets in the
relationship in terms of how much
resource you're going to put in it you
know I've had a number of cases where
I've used contract
to come in and supplement team things we
needed to get done or innovation we
needed to drive and these same tools
we've just talked about can actually be
applied in the same way so I don't think
it has much to do with you know are you
hiring talent are you outsourcing things
it really comes down to it's a
relationship and you want to manage a
relationship and these are tools you can
use to do it so we have the next
question I think we'll go for is how do
we manage misfit partners and how and
when do you realize that they are misfit
the you know it's again I am always so
amazed at how managing partner in
relationships it's actually also like
managing personal relationships and
there's nothing harder than breaking up
you know it's over
ya know that you know the good times
have been past and it's time to call a
day a day but when it does come to the
misfit partners your first step is
recognizing hey the value isn't there
that we expected the nature of why we
came together was not you know really
there and so once you've recognized that
this isn't someone I really want to put
a lot of time in quite frankly I've
always thought it's easier or badge to
just sit down and have that conversation
hey great company think the world of the
team we've been working with but when we
really sit back and look at the value
that you're getting out of this
relationship and the value that we're
getting out of this relationship I think
we can probably both agree our time
might be better spent working on other
things we'd love to stay in touch
business always changes but I think it
really does come down to that you'll
recognize that it's a misfit because
you're not seeing the value out of it
and that the partners not seeing the
value out of it and then it's having the
tough conversation the longer you
continue a misfit relationships the more
frustrated you're going to get and the
more resource you don't have to actually
allocate somewhere else and the one
thing I've learned is the fact that
budgets are always tight resources are
always tight and you're constantly
having to get the most bang for the buck
well you know it sounds like you speak
from experience and having them having
to do this or done this before so I I'm
hoping and I'm sure that's it exactly
through and maybe it goes into some of
the
next question is and it continues on of
how do you start that conversation when
you don't see that value and in the
partner yeah so yeah I would take two
steps in this one first of all you I
would have a first conversation that
really was hey let's evaluate and look
at how our relationship has developed
one of the tools I didn't put in this
jack just from a time perspective is a
partner scorecard which essentially what
we do at the beginning of the partner
relationship as we sit down and we you
look at different things we want to rank
and rate the relationship on you know
effectiveness of how we interact you
know if there are specific gifts to get
yeah how are we doing on the give to
guests but kind of a scorecard for the
relationship and then use that as a tool
that every quarter you sit down with a
partner and you say okay hey let's look
at how things are going well you can
take that same approach by sitting down
with the partner and saying hey let's
just look at what were the original
things we both wanted to get out of this
and let's look at how we feel about that
and you'll find that the discussion
comes down to yeah we were gonna go do
it yeah we never got around to it or
yeah we had that revenue target of X
number of dollars yeah we only kind of
got to forty percent of it and then
after having that kind of adult
conversation if you will about are we
getting the value out of this that we
want on it then you kind of both go back
to your corners have a deep thought and
then really come down and sit down and
say hey you know maybe this isn't the
best place where we should be but I
would challenge you in that process
think about have you actually given
everything you should have to that
relationship because it may not be a
misfit it may have been that you just
didn't align your resources for success
so I would definitely take a step back
and make sure that it really is a misfit
but having that conversation about the
value you've gotten out of is usually a
good way to get started so it makes me
think I mean so first of all I really
will take away the idea of the right
resource right partner at the right time
and it makes me this question or your
answer makes you think well is there a
time when you were able to take
something what you saw from a misfit
relationship and and realign it to what
it was more maybe not strategic but at
least you know I'm producing
opportunistic if it's truly a misfit
meaning the values not there for you and
the value is not there for the partner
it should
not going to go anywhere but coming back
to a little bit of what I was saying
sometimes something will feel like a
misfit because you don't see the value
but when you take that step back you go
Wow reason we're not getting the value
out of it was we said we're gonna go JA
dr5 Co marketing campaigns together to
make this revenue number and we only got
one done or we said hey we're gonna get
our engineers together to develop a new
innovative offering to the market and we
both got sidetracked doing our own
things so that recognition of hey it
feels like a misfit take that step back
and make sure it's not you know just a
factor of we can apply the right
resources at the right time so that in
that case you can probably get something
out of it but if it truly is a misfit no
value to either partner then it's not
going to go anywhere time to get out
okay so I'm gonna combine two questions
here we have one about can you go over
the tools again and somebody needing to
apply those immediately it looks like
and then another question about the key
performance indicators and to measure
success so maybe what I'd say there is
of the tools that you presented if
somebody needs to use those right away
which it sounds like where would you
start and then kind of go back to say
how would you measure the success of
those tools and I know you went over
those through but maybe just go back as
a highlight see ones that you would
store you'd start okay Wow let's see
where would I start on the tool you know
I think probably you know in terms of I
need to immediately get going with
something I think probably the tool that
I would go back to is really
understanding the value of the
relationship and so I would go back to
either the tool that was around
understanding the partner value the
growth potential versus the strategic
value and really you know understanding
that I probably also go back and look at
that kind of quadrant that said value to
the partner and value to the company is
that a misfit it's an opportunistic
because there's more value to the
partner that uh is it an orphan because
there's more value to us than the
partner and then is it strategic but I
think I would first get a handle on
where do my partnerships net relative to
value
that probably the the first one that I
would go back to I would also go to that
kind of end putting it in action and
probably you know write that up for that
particular relationship to that kind of
embodies everything that we went through
in the conversation on the the metrics
on the how do you measure success around
the partnerships again you know kind of
going back to that final tool of putting
it together you know it really is
looking what is it we want to get out of
this what were the objectives of the
relationship but that should have form
the key performance indicators and if we
said hey this is about distribution this
is about driving revenue opportunity
then what you should probably do is get
really crystal clear that hey in this
relationship we want to drive X number
of dollars by such and such a time frame
or a percentage growth increase in a
certain time frame if the relationship
is about new product development and our
objective is hey we want to turn out
three new products by the end of the
year so I would on the key performance
indicators always go back to why is it
we're partnering what are the objectives
of that relationship and that should
inform than the measurable goals that
you have for it yeah so basically when
you started that relationship you should
have come to an agreement understanding
of what those measures of success
indicators I think we have one we have
time for one more can everybody for
their questions I'm sorry for you not
have a time to answer all of them but I
think this is a great way to end kind of
had it so basically about being
suggestive of a venture but we're going
to end with how do you manage
accountability on your own part as well
as a part of the partner you know I
think you know this comes back down to
if you have a plan in hand in the very
beginning and you've both agreed what
you want to accomplish out of the
relationship and what the gives to
guests are going to be in the
relationship then the way I would manage
that is every quarter sitting down and
it may be a longer time frame it depends
on the nature of the business but on a
regular cadence sitting down with that
partner and saying hey these are the
things we said we're going to do these
are the objectives we said we wanted to
accomplish
how are we doing and not try to manage
it all at once at the end but instead
having that periodic update sitting down
with your partner making sure you're
still in the alignment making sure
everyone's doing what they're supposed
to do and it becomes a process I think
one of the failures that companies have
is they signed the partnering agreement
and they figure out everyone's going to
go do what they said they were gonna do
they come back together at the end of
the year as they uh what happened you
know so it's that making it part of a
rigor or continuous process well I'm
going to thank you so much Linda for
your time and the knowledge is terrific
I hope that everybody who's been in with
us today will take a chance and an
opportunity you need to learn to learn
more from Linda in one of the courses
that she's offering through the
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate and if you have any
questions you will ant try to answer the
questions that we have remaining well
there may be one last closing remark and
thank you so much I just you know
partnerships can be such an important
part of the business some companies I
find treat them as an afterthought it's
oh yeah let's have this partnership when
you really think about how partners can
move your business why you partner why
you would want to partner and make it a
part of an integrated business plan it
can do huge things for the company all
right well again when the thank you
thank you for everybody who attended and
that ends today's webinar
you